let's go back to the part where you're
getting socials under the age of 12
you're going in here's the idea you give
the fake ID yes we see it then they send
you to social to an address that you're
staying I'd use the social you go get
five credit cards then you're building
credit you go to six eighty seven twenty
then you go get a house the ID that you
use to get the social is that a fake ID
that you're using
initially it was that I was using fake
IDs but then it fairly quickly I
realized it was easier just to get the
DMV to issue me the driver's license no
real light no real light for the kid
under twelve years old under two hundred
twelve months old well keep in mind when
I create their their credit profile I
don't put the age of a twelve month old
or a ten month old kid I put that he's a
34 33 year old guy man well even if it
shows up even if it shows up in the
credit profile when they pull it fraud
alert social security number just issued
issued within the last year you know
what happens you know many times I've
been there when somebody's pulled it and
they've looked at it and they've gone
that's weird
there's a fraud alert here really what
is it you trust me if you're in a bank
using a fake ID and they got that the
loan officer says to you huh that's
strange that's not something you want to
hear I mean it's taken everything in me
not to just bolt out of the door I'm
already terrified so I'm sitting there
and then you've got the loan officer
going huh that's strange and I go you
know what is it and there's that they're
like okay it says fraud alert and I'm
like really and they're like yeah Mike
huh well what why and they go well it
says that your Social Security was
issued within last year really that is
strange and this is your social yeah
you've got my two years w-2s they go
yeah that is strange
oh and they go well and you've always
used absolutely you've got my driver's
license they're like yeah okay yeah that
is that's weird okay so anyway they just
keep right on going I'm never once had a
loan turned down because how many times
has this has happened a few times two or
three times two or three times this is
out but they could have done anything
they could have they could have called I
think there's US citizen gov which
verifies your so state of birth and
everything else they they could have
done anything they don't he just went
off I mean I have so much documentation
and there are lots of fraud alerts that
come up every time you alter your name
in any way it says fraud alert because
it'll say Matt B Cox Matthew B Cox fraud
alert two different names got it
or you know em Cox it fought alone well
this is the this is the date of birth
and it doesn't really have it it just
says issued recently it doesn't seem
right because I pulled his credit and on
the credit report yellow although it
does say fraud alert issued but then it
also says that his date of birth is 1971
or 1969 so that doesn't make sense so
they disregard it right away because
you're sitting there in front of them
and I'm a clean-cut guy and I don't
appear to be nervous or leaving so I
have all the right documents and if you
need to talk to your pallone or your
boss or whatever we need to take it this
take care of let's get going yeah I'm
good thanks they just keep going I've
had that happen much time so so when
you're using when you get a social for a
kid less than say 10 months old it's a
fake social that you're getting when
that when the bank gets the social on
there and a bank runs credit and credit
comes like or even a credit card company
MBNA you know Visa MasterCard American
Express it is when they're due to social
they're not checking how old the person
with the Social Security is I mean no I
mean they're no well let me get this
straight so so I can write out the
application myself and I can say same
name everything's the same as a social
right and I use that ten month old kid
social to get a credit card but I can
put age 34 but on here to get the social
these 10 months the creditor that gives
me the credit card for $500 or $1,000 or
$200 they don't they don't have a way of
verifying whether this person fictitious
characters 34 years old or 10 months old
know what hey first of all you know what
I miss I understand which are whether
there's two different scenarios here one
is let's say Matt Cox myself let's say I
wanted to suddenly start using a
different social security number okay I
would have an issue because I already
have a car
Pro sure these guys don't have credit
profiles Lee black does not have a
credit profile
there's no Lee black so I take Lee black
a fictitious name I take an address I
take a date of birth and a sow ship to a
ten-month-old and I run all of that I
get that boat that creates a new profile
that they that there's no disputing
information to now in the public records
they hey say hey there's some guy out
there named Lee black he was born in
1970 he's got this Social Security
number and he's got any applied for a
visa and he lives at this house now
maybe the visa says no we're not they
deny him because he has no credit well
then they say but you know we will do
mr. black will get give you a credit
card if you'll give us to 103 bucks
right 150 300 whatever yeah
so I give him the three he can still
build a credit with that absolute right
in six months in six months if I get two
or three of those in six months I've got
700 credit score's I did it over and
over again well Matt what I'm asking for
is the creditor the bank when they run a
credit on you with that social that you
put 34 years old
Equifax Experian TransUnion they don't
report back the H that matches the age
that was put on the application now
there's no way for them to verify with
Social Security other than to know that
the social security number was recently
issue and there's only one of the three
agencies that even checks and they'll
say hey this was recently issued in the
worst case scenario they'll they'll do
is say can you send us a copy of your
driving without driver's license that's
crazy so you make a copy the drivers
rest you know how many times they would
say we're not they would pull the credit
and they'd say hey this is a this is a a
like a UPS box right but you have a like
it let's say you go to UPS you get a
real address
but it says box number 200 and they
would say hey this is a UPS store and I
would say no it's not and they say well
give us a give us a water bill and I say
sure and I give them a water bill with
the house address and they go well
that's weird we have this listed as a
UPS okay yeah and they still mail it you
know it's a UPS box you're mailing it
just because I gave you a utility bill
they have little things that they ask
for people just if you're really saying
it's a residence they don't want they
want to mail it to a resident
UPS box then they ask you for something
if you can provide it you're good they
just mail it and I'm making the payments
for so long and then something happens
the guy gets into our car you know how
many times I had guys there three or
four houses are going to foreclosure the
mortgage companies are writing letters
they're writing letters saying that
they're going to do that you're going to
put you in collection we're gonna
foreclose I would make a copy of a five
car pileup where somebody had been
life-flighted out and I would make a
copy of it I'd retype it and I put my
guy's name in it then I'd write a letter
with a copy of that from his sister
saying he's in critical condition the
doctors say even if he comes out of the
coma he'll never work again you might as
well just take the house they stopped
coming around I mean most people they
stopped paying and they run it I would
stop paying but then I confront you and
say this is the reason this is what's
going on I say hey I'm thinking about
going to bankruptcy I'd write a letter
back they just thought they just go away
most people take off and that makes them
think something's wrong if you can say
to keep mine - if they called their
employer their employer says no he no
longer works here they don't just stop
answering the phone he doesn't work here
anymore
then they get a letter saying he was in
a in a he was in a car accident so I
mean of course they're gonna say they've
got a reason so they go away now we
understand what happened he was an
accident it happens he lost his job it
happens
you
[Music]